okay hi everyone another live stream
a different topic this is a review of
geo functionality and related things
for version 13 of oregon language
actually i think we've got some other
things to look at here first
oh gosh the time system option
okay let's take a look at some of these
um yes so i suggest we start with geo
and then we look at time and dates and
time okay
oh look at this this is exciting we've
got astro position i'm thrilled
yeah okay i'm afraid i'm not ready for
that today so we have a lot of material
with you on dates so so let's okay
fine fine fine
all right
new default geo range
yes so this is something you requested
it's it's the fact that when there is
an error
we you get a map of champagne say
and you can get the map of the world so
we have to change that
good okay fine
so so so notice that if you still
i mean you still get the same map as you
ask for geographics of here
right so if you specifically ask for a
location here or paris or whatever you
get that map
but if the if geographic doesn't have
information about allocation
it defaults to a wall right again
the thing i'm most interested in is the
vector geographics
yes that that is at the end so let's go
quickly through these other small things
and then we go to that it is going to
work isn't it
we believe it's going to work it's still
slower than we would like it to be but i
mean it happened with the other
geographics that it took several
iterations to get the speed right
i wonder whether there's a way of having
it come in
whether there's a some kind of way maybe
it's the the um
of having some kind of asynchronous
you know refinement
we have tried several things and we even
have the tiles in the cdn
but still
it's lower than we'd like to be
and and and there are
i mean i i think it's worth to wait for
the
gaining quality that there is in the
maps
yeah
but but we have some intermediate
suggestions you will see
okay
all right let's get that
that was skipping too far ahead
right okay multi-position spec for
geovisible region yeah so that's another
thing you had suggested
that your visible region takes a list of
positions and you just get
a list of the corresponding geo visible
seems fine to me okay
support for epilogue yes so this is
something that actually christopher's
requested and now we can have
the primitives in uh
epilogue too and they will
probably understood the only the
important thing that and here we follow
what epilogue does in graphics is that
whatever you put there is not taken into
account
in the geo range estimation
okay that's interesting but good
yeah it is exactly what epilogue does in
graphics okay
okay so this is something that will be
important in a moment and we we have
this new uh geo background which is just
the labels of the vector maps
okay
that's the labels and so in the next one
you see that we can have a list of geo
backgrounds
and they will be kind of overlaid
so for example in the first one we have
the street map with no labels and then
we put on top the vector labels
yes so this is a nice combination that
we can use oh goodness
this is a problem from entity value
actually yes we we are seeing this
recently
uh it's fixed tony has fixed this so
this this is a a case in which you see
with a single geo background
we can change the properties of one or
the other
so we are having there are two different
versions of satellite it's one with it
with a different opacity
and a different geoserver
okay
so this is just another example of how
with a list of your backgrounds
we can do rather flexible things
i mean what i don't oh i see i see i see
i see these are literally
they are graphically ordered so to speak
exactly as you place them
okay so the last one will win
or for example this is another thing in
which we can have the maps with a given
zoom on the bottom and then the the
labels with a different zoom on the top
so that you can control this is
something that the users had requested
multiple times that they want very
detailed backgrounds but not so many
labels yeah that's nice
that's nice
maybe there should be another way to
control that a higher level option to
control the labeling density
um by the way given that we're talking
about this stuff maybe somebody should
see if christopher happens to be
available
okay determine that
yeah we'll check okay
um
in other words i could imagine
geo label density or something
as an option that would be a bank
switching option
perhaps
i mean i would think that that um a
label density will be relevant for other
things too although well maybe not this
is a really a case the geo case is
really a special case of this
i think so but there are other things
that that
that is worth thinking about for labels
is what type of labels
this is where you've seen apple maps and
google maps innovate
is it just transportation which it
started with
or is it
points of interest
you know and discovery
for instance
i highly call that innovation that's
been on maps for millions of years but
anyway
read a detailed review of it you'll see
the difference
i mean is it just subway stations
or or is it like buildings and parts i
know i know i know i've seen a lot of
that stuff
they have different priorities yes
okay in any case
about the density
something that we so the styles already
come with uh
different densities for each type of
label
so maybe what we could have is a factor
that we could apply to these densities
so to make them more sparse or not for
example
that could be possible i mean the basic
point is
go ahead
no that we are already applying some
kind of density for each uh
layer of labels so
so we'll go
so in this case for example
if i said
vector label zoom level four
wow why is that so slow
it's it's yeah
it's hardly an impressive additional
number of labels
i mean if i say zoom level right because
seven the density won't change what will
change is the
[Music]
the layers it chooses to put
that's going to download a ton of data
it has to download
zoom 7 for that reason
i don't understand what happened here
why why are the labels so big
this seems wrong
no the size no no it is the size is the
appropriate for the map you are seeing
and we have many more labels but the
collision algorithm is avoiding
collisions so that's why you are not
seeing tons and tons of them oh i
understand why is this
on this scale of map
these are the labels because
the the zoom level
i'm so confused i'm sorry for italy
there is a natural zoom level which will
cover all of italy right
right and what i'm doing is i'm faking
that with respect to the
zoom level for the labels but why are
the labels so big
why did the labels get bigger between
this case
between this case here zoom level 3
and zoom level 7 why do the labels ever
get bigger
i mean the fact that they are similar in
size is what we expect the fact that
they are slightly bigger that i it's
more than slightly look it it's a factor
of two bigger
at least look at that tiny san marino
there
no
no right because you are you are
assuming you are zooming in so so that
expects uh a much larger map let's say
so that's why the font is a bit larger
for for example for country names
it's not more than a bit larger look
look
four zoom levels look at how much bigger
it is it's like a factor of
i mean at least two
for an area
yes so i think we are
we are taking this
the perhaps the this the size
the zoom from the wrong place here or
something like that
i think so
yeah we will look at it yes it's it's
true that respected more
not colliding still
but can you try geographics of
like rome
with geo zoom level goes to seven
and i don't remember if that input had
the back of what it said virgil
background yes so you need to say that
your background goes to say vector
classic
why isn't in the auto complete it is
no but it should be i mean look we
should reorder it to the top but
oh gosh this is so slow
but very beautiful
see there are many purposes for which
you don't care
about i mean it's almost like
performance goal arrow quality type
thing
because that's very beautiful
how does the font size compare in that
one with the
one where it was really big
look at that look at that magnificent
rendering
just the question is why is it so
comparatively so if i were to look at
this this is a bunch of graphics
monitors is that right
is it at least compressed and so on
yes
compressing
the representation on the front end is
compressed
i think
the input form has this standard
the input form of this doesn't have
compressed data
so if i were to say
string length
well
why look it's even look the front end is
even look at that what the heck's going
on there
see it's even spinning when i just mouse
into that region
something is very wrong here
we can see here we can't see your cursor
spinning if that's okay okay well it's
been okay
spin
that stops just from you clicking on the
image just from clicking on the image
and i've seen that in some other stuff
in 13 i think look just clicking away
from the image it spins
are you in prototype right now no okay
six megabytes of crud there
so is it in fact a compressed string it
certainly should be shouldn't it
the input form should just say
compressed graphics should it not
no
why not
compressed graphics is
you know a notebook representation a
serialization representation
if it was compressed graphics then
we wouldn't be able to actually do
things on it
okay
right we can edit things and and replace
well that's lovely but most people don't
want to edit the maps
we don't care about that
what we care about is that these maps
render fast and not five times too
slowly
right we don't care about editing the
graphics we profoundly don't care about
that
so what can we do if we ignore editing
graphics can we make it faster
all right i just i just joined very
talking about would this also affect
like if you asked for you know
part one or is this just affecting like
the interactive editing
maybe by part one i mean like if you if
you dig into the expression that is a
geographic object
i'm not sure because we didn't know what
we're talking about yet i'm really
wondering why there's so many freeways
that just end
in italy but we probably don't have the
right group of people here to answer
that
i think it's i don't think the end i
think they like change into smaller
classes of roads that get rendered
differently
we're going to towns that aren't being
shown right now or
well you can see some of them i i've had
this i've seen this before as well like
if you zoom in like for example if you
look at the i can't pronounce this frost
or something like that you can see that
the you know the the the big roads turn
into smaller roads so why is
frosty noni
got a bitmap there why does rome have a
big bitmap in its center
um
so i think yes because this
we are still using a bitmap for for this
uh
signs for for these marks markers
what kind of markers
for the city markers and for the
why
why
i mean everything else is beautiful why
do we have a i mean how many markers are
there that we have to replace with
vector
basically the
the city markers and the shields
okay so we should fix that right well
the original format was svg but we
cannot support svg for importing so
that's why we were using the sprites
the what
[Music]
we shouldn't use bitmaps
we shouldn't use bitmaps if necessary we
should change the graphics
am i making sense
so you know we can take the svg
import whatever we can if there's some
weird element that we can't import then
we have to worry about that and then
somebody can just create that piece of
graphics for us
that make sense
francisco does that make sense okay yes
yes
is there anything else that's left as a
bitmap
no that was only thing left us okay fine
let's fix it not not get blocked because
a piece of svg can't be imported
okay
okay now i want to ask the question how
can we make this faster
we don't care about editing am i making
sense
yep
so there are two there are always two
parts and and the examples further down
on speed we're showing that there is
first the download of data which is the
main bottleneck
and then when you iterate the the map
and everything is cached
these vector maps are still a few times
slower than the old maps
but but
where is that speed where is is that in
the rendering or is that in something
else
it's in the processing of all the data
placing all the
styling things in front and then
let's be very specific okay so let's
take this example as a bitmap
okay
so here let's get rid of this
that just came up instantly but that may
have been because it was cached
probably can you open the speed section
and then you have clean or fresh
examples there
so that's trying to show the first time
versus the next time
and then again with vector geographics
okay so that's five times slower
right and the under is that the typical
factor i think so and you see how the
repeated timing
once the all the vector
stuff is cast so now it takes lengths
less than a tenth of a second but it's
still five times slower well that's
actually three times slower there yeah
so that's the typical thing
okay
okay but so so
just to understand and i mean how much
bigger in the no in terms of notebook
size is this
uh in regions like this is similar in
very very populated regions i mean big
cities it's
the vector maps are bigger because they
have tons of streaming built-in
information
okay there's a comment from sander
on our live stream suggesting we try a
little experiment here
that is a bug it's fixed there's well
there's a pull request for it there's no
need to do the experiment
what is the bug
uh the raw geoposition case is much
slower than the point of geoposition
case
okay
okay i understand okay fine
okay
okay so let's come back over here
all right so let's understand what is
taking time in this flow
let's consider the case first of all
we're downloading data so the experiment
i was about to do
was just to ask the question
if we do a two-string string length of
this thing
when okay so there we've got this let's
just do this again
that's lovely and fast
okay so we've got a difference in in
size here
some of that might not i mean
that doesn't necessarily mean it was
more to send though because if it you
know first writes you know the symbol
style 500 times and that doesn't
that's right i understand that but the
this difference how is it
i can't remember now how is it send is
it sent as key value or is it sends as
boxes
does it
jose or francisco
what what are you asking about
the size in the notebook is the box size
right it's not the input form size
but no i think it's the input form size
now you can make two boxes the boxes you
know should be pretty close to the input
form you think but that can use
compression but the input form can't
correct so byte count let's just see
what that is
by counter percent five
what is that the standard form probably
no that's just the byte count of the end
memory no but down the memory
right and now this one nine
is going to be much smaller i predict
you know that's a big factor
that's because this
that's just a compressed image
right by the time it goes
it was in hex or something
go ahead but why is the
well okay i guess
i think something must be getting
removed in the input form in the first
case because the the string length of
the input forms less than the byte count
that's very odd i mean i guess there
could be non-ascii stuff but i i bet
it's that the input form is
getting rid of
some stuff
it shouldn't be
generally
the expert representation takes some
additional space
maybe that's it then i mean if if it
just has a ton of just symbolic stuff
yeah i guess that's true because you
know if an expert is like at least 64
bytes or something
i mean or 64 bits and and uh you know
you could have just a couple bites in a
string that might be shorter
i um
what the heck is all that
this is just completely uncompressed
stuff
right
so what got sent over the wire yeah
so the data came in this um
how is it called francisco the what we
read with protobuf pdf
yes the protocol buffer so it's
compressed the data is compressing a
very
efficient format how much does it
compress
uh
well we have the whole world for all the
zoom levels in 44 gigabytes
so it's
that's quite compressed we expanded
everything was
yes
how big was it when it expanded
uh
it was kind of
uh
almost a terabyte i think
when we had all the database done
so okay so that's a factor of a um
thousand divided by 40
that's a factor of like 20.
right
this is where it's absolutely gets
pathetic isn't it
25 yeah
okay
it's kind of an interesting statement on
our civilization that we're 44 gigabytes
of mapping data
i wonder how much of that is forests and
things and how much of that is human
created
um okay never mind that
uh
okay
so
we think there might be a compressional
factor of 25 in the transmission
again
somebody must have have
profiled this what takes time
in the vector map case what takes time
don't say everything
just say just go through what are the
stages and how much time do they take
what takes what percentage of the time
let's see so the first time that we have
a map
we have to do some pre-processing of
styles we cache that
and this lasts for how long francisco a
week or something like that just in case
we we make changes
and then
in the first
right is a week
a week yes so
so then now we have to download the data
so wait wait wait wait wait yeah that's
a pre-processing so we're talking back
to maps here yes
correct and you're saying there's a
pre-processing of the vector map
of the style so
so the style has some pre-processing
that we have
cached
but it has to be done from time to time
and then
we download the date sorry
sorry we download the data
and then
it's it's the fact that we download
geometric data without styling and we
have to put together the styling
information with the data information
that also takes
some time not as much as downloading
but it's probably
um okay so let's walk through this again
okay so hold on so first of all there's
pre-processing on the vector data
that is done on the server side
which we do automatically down to some
zoom level presumably but only
i mean why don't we just know which
tiles people have ever requested why
don't we just basically do
pre-processing for all of those tiles
no no no no first
because i first was talking about the
styles so so the first thing we process
is the style information so let's say
rom is black
right and that takes a few seconds
downloading processing that and that's
something that we can share because that
we only have eight styles so we can
achieve them for a week
so i'm sorry styles of what are we
talking about the style for every tile
on the map or are we talking about one
central set of styles
something like vector classic
what is in the style is it just how to
render a a level one freeware level two
freeway a forest this that and the other
what are you talking about what's in the
styles
yes it's exactly that yes exactly that
italy uses gray rom uses black
highways uses orange etc okay fine how
many different categories so there might
be a hundred things 100 different kinds
of things for which we have to define
the style 241 yes
241 okay a decent estimate on my part
okay
all right
okay
that takes uh
some time
why and that's that's why 241 things is
not very many what are we doing there
we're saying
it's this kind of orange and so on was
that is that just the download time that
it has to do once a week but there's no
actual is it actually computing
something or is it just downloading
something
not right it has to compute the json
file to convert that to
the format of the
so to interpret the json file basically
the importing of the file and
interpreting it
that just sounds completely crazy
but that takes more than about you know
a tiny fraction of a second 241 things
241 colors how can that take more than
just like microseconds
i'm confused
i mean i started listing things in order
and this is the first step but it's it's
a minor step so perhaps we can we can
but let's find out how long it takes
because it should take
well under
a tenth of a second from what you
described that it's doing
it well it's also important the images
images no no why are there bitmap images
you told me hold on hold on what is this
step i thought you told me it is the
definition of styles it has nothing to
do with bitmap images
is it styles or is it styling of images
for example these icons are part of the
style also
so it's important there won't be any
more icons like that everything is going
to be vector graphics
okay fine all right so so
you're caching the styling information
all right fine 241 items each one is a
little expression that represents
certain styling
is that correct
okay stephen right and all the rules
that involve
what about rules what rules what rules
what do you mean rules no all the rules
of the style like for example the color
or the size the okay fine the fact that
it has some size at some zoom a
different size another zoom et cetera
okay that could get tricky okay
right right right so so it's almost a
multiplication because you have 14
different zoom levels
for 240 okay all right now you're now
making more sense
okay all right i get it so that's first
thing that's done
next so i sent you a command which will
activate timing debugging so it will be
easier to discuss that
so evaluate what i sent in chat and then
do a map
okay so let's try this map
here so this is cumulative what you see
at the end of of indentation is
accumulated right
okay let me try the same thing with a
with a vector
in the vector
case by the way it would be nice if that
was computable data
that it returns
the
report yeah
that's a good idea
why is this why is did you see it didn't
scroll properly did you get what i'm
saying it didn't scroll properly that is
a that i've seen this with the version
13 front end recently
look at that when i click on the map
okay it's spinning
did you get do you get what i'm saying
yeah i'll pass this part of the
recording to the front end team
it's just wrong really wrong okay
so let's see if that's related to the
thing that you reported earlier to john
that the
you're typing after
large no i don't think so that that's an
old problem
okay that's an old problem this is a new
problem this is a new problem that that
just rendering things is super slow
okay let's look here
so this is the
the previous version
okay parsing options okay that takes no
time geo evaluate that takes no time
okay let's see so this is cumulative
times right
yes so
focus first on the on the numbers on the
left
and then
okay but the place where it starts
getting big so this is all
you know fractions of micros of
milliseconds
right so this is a case that you had
cached already
so that's why i see what you're saying
okay so jio
so change the rom to some other place
yeah yeah i will
well well
okay hold on
um
okay so let's just look at this so then
i don't understand if it's cumulative
how could it be triple triple zero five
at the end for handling
i don't understand no it's good
communicative with respect to the
indented things that you see before
so for example in section five you see
these various things that are indented i
see so this is nine
okay so this
nine b
nine c
okay so here that's the time it's a
bitmap
okay we have indented those cases which
we
usually see is lower so we want to
refine the information there
okay so the big thing here is this one
here road shield motorway blah blah blah
collisions time that was the big the big
time sink in this case
right because probably there are
hundreds or thousands of those roads and
we have to worry about them
but why what's it doing there though i
mean that's not the front-end rendering
time like what processing is it doing
there
each one comes with a name and we have
to process the collision algorithm and
we have to process the labels
we want to curve the labels adapted to
their to the same but there's a there's
a problem here
these there are no road labels
look at the well there are a few they're
a1 and 812 there are three road labels
so in all that time
of
of
0.12 seconds
the only thing it managed to do was to
determine the positions of three labels
yes but it's difficult in advance to
know whether they're going to succeed or
not
i understand but essentially all of them
fail which suggests that there might be
better a better heuristic
and by the way notice that in the bitmap
none of those labels make it at all
am i making sense yes so that was
processed with a different
uh program
and
also wait a minute this
okay
so the raster tiles were produced i
don't think we should have road labels
like this by default
on our maps
i i just think unless you're really
doing street
well it depends what level i mean at
this level when you're zoomed out this
far
i really seems surprising that we want
those anyway it's a different issue
let's look at the corresponding thing
with a place we didn't know about
already
uh let's try something like
um
manchester i don't know why i'm picking
that but i'm figuring nobody actually
asked for that by the way i noticed
there's a bug with okay
downloading geotiles
right so you see that this is there the
main section now
okay why is this not scrolling it's not
scrolling look at this
it's frozen this is exactly what i've
seen with tons of other stuff recently
with version 13. okay there is a bug
okay
okay
so
getting tiles eight seconds
what's all this stuff here attaching
directives well so getting tiles with
eight seconds so right there we have our
main
you know
issue so now let's look at the
corresponding thing over here
that was just blindingly fast wait a
minute what happened here
oh wow it got the manchester in
massachusetts
that's not the one you intended
i was i don't know why i was thinking
more in the uk
but anyway never mind that
um
i got the uk
well that's because it's a different
heuristic base i i'm surprised it has
any idea what my geolocation is
okay why is this okay first of all this
map has much better labeling than this
one
oh it's a zoom level seven well who
knows what it was
something is very weird here look look
at the size of these labels they're just
wrong
is that a consequence of the zoom level
the size of the texts
no in general the new vector maps has
have
bigger labels because it increases
readability
so vector classic may have
slightly
too big or too bold
okay okay okay but there's a problem
there but by the way i'm noticing a
comment on the live stream there should
be a way to switch off the stupid street
names
which i agree with we don't want street
names that's a different kind of map
than
you know sort of our most common kind of
map
making sense i mean really you know
there's probably a bigger project which
is sort of
specifying which layers you want
but right but look at this this doesn't
have the stupid street names this one
does
we should lose them by default
at this zoom level
i look maybe i'm being unfair because i
picked a zoom level
okay but this was just blindingly fast
do you think that's because we already
cached it or something or what
no no we have improved a lot over the
years there's a load of these raster
tiles and of course everything is
prepared in raster
image already well here geo image
download time 0.7 seconds okay right
whereas here
where is it
so it was like seven seconds here
is that just because it's downloading 10
times as much data or is it
is in some sort of processing thing
i think the processing is separate the
business is separate yeah okay so let's
understand the protobuf data here we
think the protobuf is is factor of 25
compressed
how big is the data here
we can presumably determine that by
simply asking here in line 20.
what oh god this is crazy look at this
this is spinning again
it's still spinning
just from clicking there
i think there's some kind of memory leak
look at this
i can't use this notebook now
i'm taking timestamps every time this
happens
12 megabytes
okay so assume that that's in the
protobuf thing is factual 25.
hold on though i mean how much
like
does does the does the pdf file like
does it have a bunch of other junk in it
like is the file is this
refined down to 12 megabytes
we download more things so in vector
maps
we together with the tiles needed we
download the area too so that if you
move a bit to the side you already have
those tiles
it also decreases the number of tiles
because we placed them in the cdn and we
had some limits of of number of files
there so
so we group we don't load tiles in
groups
sorry that was the bitmap case of the
vector case the vector case
i mean i think we do it also with the
with the
image with the raster tiles but not as
aggressively as we do it with the vector
do you remember the numbers francisco of
the meta times
no no
right so in the case of raster
so there is a concept that to
decrease the number of files
we have
a kind of meta tile which is an 8x8
group of tiles
and that's what you download
in the case of the case of bitmap but
what about the case of vector no
indication no no no in the case of
vector in the case of bitmap it's stored
in the server also in eight by eight but
but you download uh each one in a
separate way
so yeah so wait a minute wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you're
telling me that when i download this so
this is crazy by the way what you're
telling me you're telling me
that
this thing is spinning again
just crazy
it's just it's still spinning so this is
getting worse it spins longer for longer
each time okay just like you would
expect from some kind of memory leak
yeah
okay
but maybe you should check your memory
usage but but but i mean so is that
because so
is is the reason for that that basically
uh there's some overhead in
the the pbf files and so you want to
send over you know one big file if
you're gonna have to download many tiles
as opposed to with images where there's
very little overhead and sending a
compressed image is that isn't that why
there's a difference there
no i think that what they're saying is
okay so first point is when you request
a particular region chances are you
don't hit a tile on the nose
you have to have the the the nine patch
effectively
am i correct guys
yes typically a map has of the order of
10 12 times
right but typically
a given map right you could hit the tile
on the nose you exactly want the tile to
the tile boundaries but normally you
have a three by three region probably
where the tile you hit is the one in the
center but they're little pieces of some
of the
well i don't know whether it's always no
no
obviously if the centering is off to one
side
right
in fact you would expect that you would
need in a three by three region of tiles
right
if you imagine that the center point
yeah yeah you you will only need four
you'll always need four right
if you have an o3 you could request a
region like if you request if a zoom
level five tile is n miles across you
know then if you request a giant area
with zoom level five then it might need
20 miles but at the natural level
at a natural zoom level you would
naturally need four wouldn't you
i think it's more like
typical maps are a bit rectangular and
they typically have four by three times
say
okay because partly because of
projection
yes exactly projection needs a bit more
and
and tiles are
256 pixels and our maps are
500 600 pixels something
okay fine but but okay so all right so
you think you're decently optimizing and
there's not an issue there's not some
crazy thing about how you know we need
to double the size of the cdn or
something
um
i mean the estimation of tiles has
worked very well for raster tiles in the
past
now in the cdn we may be doing a bit too
much or eight by eight
i mean downloading chunks of 64 may be a
bit too aggressive so we have been
thinking of changing that to four by
four
so well four by four relative to 64.
i don't understand it's it's 16 versus
versus 64. exactly so
that's fracture of eight
f four four four sorry
yeah so if we manage to have a map that
only needs one of these four by four
then yes it will be four times faster
well that's not very worth having i mean
is there an issue this isn't an issue in
the address space in cdn
exactly that's why initially we we try
to be aggressive in decreasing the
number of files we put there
is there an issue with address space on
cdn
i can't imagine it
we were told not to use too much not to
have too many files okay well i think
that's nonsense
i think if worst case we have to pay for
more space in cdn
okay this is not a problem
the global cdn of the world is big
enough to accommodate our files
we have been thinking of of doing these
tests of of decreasing to 4x4 and seeing
how much that helps in general with
speed
by the way i can think of some
interesting if i think the cdm we're
using is pretty good but um i realize
that there are some uh crypto related
cdns or things which act like cdns that
we could be using
spend some of our cryptocurrency on
cdn space
anyway never mind it's different issue
um
okay
so let's go back here
so
again i want to review so that there are
two issues first of all this doesn't
look very good and second of all it's
really slow
so
what else is making it slow
so it's bigger to download than the
previous one
yes i think this this the second main
thing in
taking time is perhaps the collision
algorithm for labels
the whole process of of
processing sizes
breaking into letters adapting the
letters to the curves of the streets of
or the roads or the rivers
they san francisco i think that's the
second thing
well right not in this particular map
because we are not
doing this uh
reveal form letters but in other cases
when using yes
also okay
all right
what is it gonna take to grind this okay
so
do you have suggestions for what to do
given that this is dog slow
so i'm sure that as it happened the
previous time in in a couple of cycles
more we will manage to find tricks and
ways to improve this just so far we
haven't right this is vector labels on
top of a bitmap map right exactly yeah
and that looks already pretty good
but of course in order to download the
labels we have to download the vector
data because the labels are in the
vector data no but you don't have to
download all the vector data we could
make a pure labels you know labels layer
right
um i francisco do you have definitely
without question
i'm sure we can do it no it's possible
we haven't done that but but yes
so i think we should do a totally
different layer of data exactly
that's right
my guess is that should be the default
for right now
am i making sense
um
yes yes i i understand that yeah i just
don't know how much it will take us to
to produce that layer
i also think these labels are way too
big
way too big really ugly
um
bob is commenting that many decimal
places in the vector data there have to
be the world is a big place
to specify
something you've got to be down to a
meter right
or something
and that's by definition right from when
when was it 10 million meters well
when napoleon originally defined the
meter by by doing the what's it around
the earth how many meters is the
circumference of the earth
yes exactly 15 million
yeah
um
i mean 10 million is the quota meridian
so the total is 40.
right
okay so that's why you need those many
bits
um
do protobuffer files
store numbers as text or binary
somebody's asking here
i think it's i i'm not sure i think it's
binary because basically osm used to use
xml for everything
and then they just compress it and then
they then they switched over to using
like pdf and my understanding is because
that's a binary format and it's like a
factor the compressed version's like a
factor of two smaller
okay
but if people otherwise ppf protobuffer
nothing to do with pdf portable document
um
there are all sorts of comments here
about pinch zoom i think it's the wrong
group but i don't know what's happened i
mean i don't know why we don't have
pinch zoom does anybody know the the
argument for a long time was various
things to do with the
uh ui stack that we were using but
that's been solved for a couple of years
now
we should bring that at the very least
to um
uh
the user assistance meeting brady okay
okay
so let's go back to what we should be
doing here so i think the best
compromise for this version is
uh vector labels
the default being vector labels
non-vector
background which i think will still be
blindingly fast assuming you have a
separate vector layer
makes a label layer
makes sense
um
yes
so
but here i rely on francisco do you
think it's we can do in in a few weeks
this new layer francisco
uh
we will need to see that because yes
that's a lot of data to process and
well it throws a lot of data in the end
it's a rather small amount of data in
the end
right in the end but but to
to get all the data is to actually
go through all these
well then we'll do it when we do it but
then when we first release we'll we'll
have done hopefully a decent number of
the most prominent tiles and then we'll
gradually go through and do the other
tiles
right i see
yep
um perhaps it's something we can
release
i mean uh improve after the release
right
well yeah but i mean that's because it
just comes from yourself look these
labels are too big okay no question
about it these labels are too big
they're ugly and too
big but by the way they have exactly the
same size as the
raster labels
only that we always show a different
zoom layer that a different zoom level
that the natural zoom level for this
map well fine but whatever we were doing
we optimized it so let's do it again
right
this is just wrong what we're seeing
here is wrong
right but because if you compare these
two maps for example they actually have
this same size of the labels which maps
i think the argument is that the rat the
raster maps because we we show raster
maps smaller than they're supposed to
yes so if you show them at their correct
quote-unquote correct size okay i'm
saying those labels are the wrong size
the labels at the quotes correct size
that somebody decided were the correct
size are not the correct size and what
we had done before was something that
made the labels come out looking correct
am i making sense
we didn't get to show them too small
um well this is too big
yes this may be too big and it's
unfortunate that the only country chosen
is the democratic republic of congo
which is so long
but i don't care about that that's not
the problem the problem is these things
labels are too big
it's really a simple problem that factor
of two too big or at least
like sixty percent too big
i think i also had some issues where i
was doing geographic stuff you know with
vector classic
and uh
you know i was like trying to display
data and the labels were sufficiently
big that some of the data was sort of
like hard to to make out
right these scaled fonts what happens
when you magnify it
are they you know or they
they're scaled yeah okay
okay it's just wrong let's fix it okay
simple as that
you know that would be about the right
size for those labels
you get what i'm saying
yep
yeah but probably we're going to apply
it again let's go on to the rest of the
review because i think we we know we
have to do things here again these these
stupid look at this look at this this is
just wrong okay get rid of those things
why do we see those
i mean this is a map it's not i think
it's not uncommon to have those like i
think google maps now has i understand
that but that's because those are street
maps for people trying to drive cars
around
which is not what we're primarily
providing
we're providing geographical maps
so we can control
the zoom level at which they appear so
perhaps it's a matter of pushing some of
these uh i think that will be good yes
at the level where you're looking
primarily at cities i don't think road
labels should appear
well sometimes you are interested on how
to get into i mean any road labels like
street names
no at the level where you're seeing
whole cities like this i see okay
right
i mean at this level it's okay
that's okay that's probably useful at
that level
but when you see when the the thing is
the multi-map i don't know i mean again
this is something that we should
probably have
i'm sorry
but but this is the same zoom level
or not
i don't think so
can't imagine it
champagne is a lot smaller than oslo
exactly it's the same size it's about
radius of
10 miles
but of course oslo is bigger
is it
i mean i i i mean another thing though
is i think you would be complaining with
the champagne one of those labels were
blue
so i mean it's just kind of a quirk of
the norwegian road
uh signage
okay i was gonna say it's interesting
that the champagne one we're getting the
you know u.s highways but not the
interstates the interstates would pop a
lot more
that's true and that's weird i think in
vector we do the we now show the
opposites if you change the geographics
here to vector classic for example
i don't think i can hear what may not be
well i don't we'll do it
um
background to
vector classic
oh god
that looks terrible it just looks
frigging terrible
i mean those labels i agree it might be
a little small but this just looks
terrible
come on guys
we've got to do better than this this is
not useful
but
i always find this map particularly nice
so huvana may be a bit too large but the
other ones are very nice
which other
ones what i don't like is that
all of them are crossed out by something
am i the only one who thinks that
every single word is crossed out by a
line
well i think that's just the nature of
the fact that those things are
intersections right i don't know on the
map right so i think that doesn't look
so bad
i mean i think the urbana one in
particular has a certain like because
it's so big there's a lot of stuff going
on behind it
so it makes it can we if we're going to
review the appearance of this we should
get jeremy
so by the way i mean just just in terms
of the quote-unquote correct sizes and
stuff like that so i mean if you go to
like openstreetmap.com and look at you
know what the the sizes they have they
have them much smaller much more like
the the current the raster we're just
getting it wrong guys it's as simple as
that we're getting it wrong so let's fix
it
going slightly too small and having more
elegant maps is better than having great
big things that are that are huge like
this
am i making sense
yep okay and let's could you make sure
that you do a review of this with jeremy
and i'll be in it if i need to be
fair yep
okay let's go on with the other things
we have to look at and and i suggest the
compromise which we should look at of
using vector labels and you know bitmap
background for now
assuming that that can be done
blindingly fast
that making sense yep
okay so let's see
we were
yes um so there are a couple of
questions on names and um
yeah
okay and one thing that should be pinned
here
is this issue about about now that we
can do multiple layers
right being able to describe which
layers you want like streets versus this
versus that
yeah that's in the
plans um
sandra's complaining about in africa the
fact that we're only labeling three
countries look the basic problem is the
labels are too big guys it's really the
only huge problem
um
yes
[Music]
so perhaps the the
the important ones are the last two ones
about the names we want to talk about
hold on sometimes you auto rasterize to
avoid projection problems with vector
primitives
yes so
so the particularly for a simultaneous
projections in which the topology of
things change
sometimes
we get those wrong so we are auto
rasterizing some of these cases for a
moment that's just fine
um
much better that than we have a great
big you know poking antarctica sticking
in a straight line
because of the fact that was the way it
was rest you know that was the way the
vectors went
yeah so these you have seen already the
fact that when you scale the maps the
the the labels scale with the
with the map
rather than stain
and then
of course if
we're talking about graphic design we
really really really should get
you want me to try to get them yes now
please okay i will try
i think we should call team two um i i'm
gonna have to leave unfortunately
so this was about the choice of which
one
is should be default when we make this
default
i don't know
i don't know i mean that's a graphic
design question
i mean there was definitely shouldn't be
the default
so if you go if you go back to the top i
think this is actually the issue i was
talking about before where i end up
using um vector minimal instead of
vector classic because uh
uh
like if you try and put data over like
the zoom level six vector classic
it's it's kind of like i don't know i
think that the thicknesses are kind of
weird like you can't vector classic is
just frigging ugly
it's just frigging ugly with those great
big black things in it
it's just wrong i mean that's much
better
back to minimal
is vector minimal a reasonable a
reasonable thing in the end
um i think the team was suggesting
vector business
that doesn't look bad either i don't
know what the difference between these
two is i mean i and
victor minimal has less elements than
vector business actually i think they
have
but we don't want these great big things
come on guys look at this we do not want
that
freeway label the same size as chicago
just wrong
at this level
disappointingly wrong i mean at that
level fine it's got actual streets and
so on at this level ridiculous
in my view
i think that's easy to change
i mean something like google maps i mean
i don't think they're that intrusive but
it's mostly just because they're you
know that the shield is like you know
three times the thickness of the road
right which is to say not very not very
big yeah right this is where it's absurd
this thing is like mega sized
it's completely stealing the attention
yeah yeah it's just wrong it's just
totally wrong guys
sorry
okay i have no opinion about this i
think we're gonna have to do a separate
graphic design review here
okay
okay
let's plan on that i did text jeremy i
don't know okay all right while we're at
it let's try and just knock off a couple
of these other things before we wrap up
here
um
i'm really glad that that finally after
how many years is it we managed to get
this vector stuff flowing through the
system
although now we just have to figure out
how to optimize it and for goodness sake
this is just such an ugly map
please let's fix it
okay
yeah but it's mostly the labels right
it's if the label is smaller if the
labels were not there this map will be
beautiful
the lab is great except for the fact
that the labels are completely wrong
simple as that completely wrong
okay
okay
okay
okay
all right should we should we just take
a quick look at some of these things
like time system for example
uh we can it it's a whole new world so
and and i know you always have
questions about the relativity part
so well i don't know why
but
oh boy
so this is
so i think the way to see these is is
the final freedom in date objects so we
have right now granularities
calendars time zones so this was the
final one or at least one missing the
time systems
to be absolutely precise so the time
system determines the coordinate if i
say it is midnight precisely right now
the question is what does that actually
mean
with respect to the position of the
earth or whatever else exactly is it
with respect to atomic clocks or with
respect to the motion of the planets or
the rotation of the earth
these things were synchronized
decades ago but by now they have
departed minutes
so it's important
um
what do you mean
when were they synchronized
for example they decided to
to
align the atomic clocks in
1956 i think or 58
with the time that the astronomers were
using
wow okay
early atomic clocks yeah yeah i think
the first one was in in england 56
and
these things were synchronized and since
then they have been departing and those
are the famous sleep seconds
okay
okay so it's an atomic clock sitting in
a certain gravitational field
and the earth is spinning and it's
glitching around
and
the question is what time is it actually
yeah so thai is is an atomic clock it's
an average of hundreds of atomic clocks
on the geoid
and with the earth rotating and inside
the gravitational field so so it's the
real clock
yeah i understand it unless the earth
changes its density or something and
those you know those clocks are going to
stay at the same rate
exactly yeah so then but it also looks
like there's stuff like the the
different policies for incorporating
leap seconds and stuff like that
just just looking at the list
yeah so i think i think after thai the
next one is ut1 which is the
uh badly named
universal time which is the time that
follows the rotation of the earth and if
the earth
slows down or speeds up it will be
noticed there
okay
so then we have utc which is a a
convention
that is it's following tie but always
with us with an integer difference
with respect to tie in seconds so that
it's it's always less than a second from
you to one
okay
and so it's following ut1 so utc is
always less than a second from beauty
one but
an integer number of lip seconds from
respect to time so it's as precise as
tie
but represents closely what ut1
represents i see
then the other ones no in roger's
convention for how this works there
should be a diagram of all of this here
yes i mean
i think this needs a diagram of the
relations between them
explaining what each one is in a diagram
it's not easy
but we said enough yeah the relations
okay so just just for my education very
centric
what is barry centric with respect to
what very center of what
of this of the solar system when when
i say that here solar system barycentric
coordinate time
because geocentric is with respect to
the center of the earth presumably
the yes exactly
okay so what do you mean by so it's
relative to the center of the sun
no the solar system very center which is
not exactly the center of the sun it's
likely outside the sun
okay
boy jupiter is heavy okay yeah right
have fun
and so
um
yeah so this is the
this is essentially the the time of the
astronomers the time if you want to
follow galaxies and planets etc
it's a time that is not affected by the
gravitational field and speed of the
earth
but how does it relate to thai
well there is there is a bunch of of co
of conversion so from thai we go to
t uh to tcg
tcg is the
is the bar is this time at the center of
the earth
and it's it's the
it's the time that you would have at a
point
that is moving with the speed of the
earth
around the sun
but without the gravitational field of
the earth
i see
so it has been corrected there is no
gravitational field there
so actually it's funny because
tie is running faster sorry slower than
tcg because tie is inside the
gravitational field
of the earth but tcg is not
right
okay but it still has
time dilation from the fact that it's
going at a certain speed relative to
exactly so so wait a minute so that so
that which which is the rest frame
so the rest frame for tcg is is this
point that is at the center of the earth
but okay
t
c b is the solar system okay fine so so
in other words
tcg is
its clock is running slower than the one
for the solar system
because it's moving
relative to the solar system right
and so
so then there is a
a transformation from tcg to tdb and
that has these oscillations due to the
fact that the earth is going
at a different speed
and at different points in the
gravitational field of the sun
so there are oscillations there
annual oscillations
which are about one millisecond
completed
and
one millisecond over what period of time
a year
wow okay
yes so these things accumulate and for
example
uh it said that the if we take into
account the gravitational field of the
earth the core of the earth
is about two and a half years younger
than the surface of the earth
that's a nice fact
i like that fact
it's not that big an effect is it over
4.6 billion years exactly yeah but but i
mean two and a half years it's quite a
lot
right it's it's not saying it's
milliseconds
no i mean if you'd asked me to estimate
that i would have guessed it wasn't
milliseconds but i did that's
interesting number
i see so the extreme case of that
would be
well
in the schwa solution the extreme case
is the center of the well that is that
right i mean the
extreme cases where the center doesn't
evolve at all
presumably
but time is is
stopped in the center
at the horizon yes so if you compare the
time at the horizon with the time
outside the gravitational field it is an
infinite factor
right but for the earth it's not an
infinite factor right
interesting okay
okay
wow okay
all right i think i understand this this
is cool is this all implemented now
yes so
yeah so nick has implemented all this
yeah it's specifically implemented in
data objects and also in julian date we
haven't generalized it to date list or
absolute time because
they're frankly kind of older
representations of time and it's hard to
carry around information like time
system yeah i think i mean look absolute
time
eventually that will need to have it but
i mean it's this is a small effect on
that scale right yeah and right it
doesn't really make sense seven time
objects because we need to know where
you are on
an actual timeline rather with than
within a 24-hour cycle so it really only
makes sense in date objects and then
julian date or other things that
specifically need to account for the
differences in time measurement
right it's only relevant for an absolute
thing on the absolute time scale not the
it's 7 p.m
on some day
right this is consulting ephemeris
of of what is the earth in the solar
system
right
and do we get to have
i mean yeah okay fine so every
spacecraft and principle needs its own
time zone i mean time system system
yes once we connect to spice
which i think we will do for 31
then we will have all those two
so then then this time system thing will
say voyager 1 or something somewhere
here one of those
are true
well i'm not sure yet
we are going to have access to the
information but i don't know how much is
going to be propagated certainly all the
astro staff will know about it
but i have i don't have the the full
design of
okay fair enough i mean because because
in principle we should be able to have a
time system i mean some part of this is
crazy but i mean we should be able to
have you know serious time or something
i mean in other words we should be able
to know
let's see that relative okay wait a
minute let me just be unconfused here
perhaps i should say something here all
this has been developed for the solar
system so all this stuff
is very well developed for the solar
system for example light deflection by
the sun and the planets
but there are not a general formalism to
do this in full general relativity that
would be full numerical relativity
that's way too much yeah yeah right
so so you might expect some relativity
in all of these
mainly if it is within the solar system
but not so much for example there is no
cosmology here
right i understand that's a separate
story exactly and doesn't really need to
you know
the question of of you know
did the big bang what what time of day
did the big bang occur at 3 pm is hardly
the most sensible question
and
i wonder does one have enough data no
one doesn't have enough data to answer
that even close no not even not even one
needs vastly more precision to answer
that question
right right
we didn't know enough about the
beginning
right
astral possession
yes so i i i'm not prepared for that so
that's going to still evolve
okay
okay yes are we are we going to get some
astro graphics as well
not in this version so that will be a
certain one so this time i want to have
control on time and the coordinate
systems so it's a bit like the
geoposition person
and it's going to be just
the
astral position so this
we don't need like a tangent plane for
to the celestial sphere or anything like
that
um
but so this will allow us if we say
astral position of serious
minus astral position of or
we don't have astro distance yet
no not yet
so so this is
i mean
one of the numbers inside astroposition
will be the distance or equivalent to
distance you can have parallax for
example which is equivalent to the earth
right
so so astronomers sometimes give
parallax as distance information instead
of information right
oh instead of distance right but so this
particular thing so there'll be the
conversions between different astro
coordinate systems here but that's the
main thing that will exist here exactly
yes okay
and you will be able to say
things like i'm using
coordinates which are corrected of light
time so it will be like the time of
observation rather than the time of a
mission yeah i guess
but i hope that there'll also be
something where you can get raw xyz
coordinates
of some kind so that you can like plot
them and
you know plot nearby stars and things
exactly so so see the penultimate line
there so you have the numbers the frame
and then the coordinate system and then
there's where you say i want spherical
coordinates or xyz coordinates or i see
or a projection or whatever
nice
that's a little different from what
geoposition does right because
geoposition doesn't have
you don't
limit geo position it's only geogrid
position that allows you to project to a
particular projection right
right so in geo position we have the
separation of the three main cases to
position the position x y c and the
aggregate position
so so my plan here is to have them all
accumulated in the
in this third argument which will be
more flexible and will allow you to say
and i want rather than having x y c i
want y c x
and i want them in kilometers
rather than in astronomical units i see
things like that
right okay
okay well it's very cool um the zoo of
possibilities is much larger in this
case
and people don't use so much projections
for example as in sng
right but what's much more relevant is
ecliptic coordinates or whatever those
things are all those kinds of things
exactly okay well very cool okay we have
some questions on the
live stream um
obviously asking when's the next q a for
the physics project yes we should have
one of those we should have one of those
overdue for that
um bob was asking how would we ask that
question about the earth's core being
two years younger
than
the earth's surface
do we have what what is the
what would we compute is it something
where we say
date
you know date minus 4.6 billion years
time system arrow
geocentric time versus time system arrow
tt terrestrial time isn't that what it
would be
well it could be implemented via a
change of
of time system now as i said before the
time system that is defined for the
center of the earth is one that does not
consider the gravitational field so we
actually don't yet have a time system
that is the true core
we could add it
but it's not one that is used in in
astro physics right
right fair enough
okay
um
let's see
ethan is suggesting adding some examples
once we have the information from
spacecraft on fake interstellar time
warps
yes
hans is asking about relation of astro
position to pulsars i assume that our
pulsar data will flow correctly into
astral position i mean presumably our
star positions will
eventually we have to move things to
return astral positions like i don't
know sun position one position etc so
like we did with geo
returning your positions rather than
coordinates
and then we will need a way of
expressing orbits so word lines and
saying things like from this location
where do you see this wall line and it
will do the computation
that's a that's again a trajectory story
much as we have the flight path as much
as we had with um
oh gosh what was the other thing we were
just doing just yesterday that needed
trajectories
oh gosh there's a different thing so
flight path needs trajectories
oh i forget
um yeah this is a matter of trajectory
so of integrating light rays and you
will have to say oh it's been deflected
by sun
we can do that
right
um
what wait what are you saying sorry
yes if we are observing something from
the earth and the light ray comes very
close to the sun this astroposition will
have to take into account the light
difference oh gosh gravitational lensing
really
yes i mean the
the deflection by the sun is really
important
i mean there are many facts there are
like those and effects
including the fact that there is a
variation because the earth moves
the object original may be moving and we
have the catalog data from
the year 2000
you mean the proper motion of the actual
the promotion exactly proper motion
that's the proper name yes that's a
that's a big effect but i didn't think
the gravitational lensing around the sun
was a big effect unless the star was
really close to the sun
some some detectors can now see the
light deflection by the fact that
jupiter is not fully spherical
so
it's it's getting really precise
well i did love the idea of having an
actual telescope
that you know where the focal point
is way out somewhere in the i don't know
in the oort cloud or something the
telescope made by
the gravitational lensing of the sun
did you see that that proposal
no
that was kind of a year or so ago
you send a spacecraft out to the point
that is the focal point for the
gravitational lensing done by the sun
and then you use that to look at other
things further out in the solar system
um
anyway okay i think those are rather
subtle effects that i'm not sure can be
built into our default
you know
basic system
um
but fair enough but i mean it seems like
the most obvious things i mean do we
have the proper motion data for the
stars
we do and and truman has been
constructing a few
word from repository functions that
connect to
catalogs out there which are huge and
contain all that information very
precisely
okay
yeah so
yeah i mean the proper motion of stars
over historical times
is it a single vector i mean they don't
they just
that they're just in
in unaccelerated motion is that true yes
so all observations are approximated by
linear motion
but is it a good approximation over
thousands of years that the stars are an
inertial motion
i i think so they are so far that from
our
i mean obviously ones that are not at
binaries and things like that clearly
not an inertial motion
yes but those those will move relatively
little i mean
yeah i mean i assume there are other
cases where the where there are stars
isn't the proxima centauri isn't that
one of the things that's in a
you know a distant ternary system
that
is i mean there must be there must be
intermediate cases from tight binaries
to things which are just random stars
floating around on their own
right so these are the things that jeff
knows much better than i do fair enough
fair enough fair enough
i mean i will make sure that we have to
have to discuss these things when we
review this okay okay fine but then but
then i mean the types of things we'll
get not in 130
are things where we can make star charts
and so on
exactly all the graphical stuff will
come later and we'll make use of these
computations
right
well terrific
okay
and presumably wait a minute presumably
in astral position we'll also be able to
compute
the positions of planets and things
we already have those positions in
astronomical data
right right and because as i said i'm
planning to link to spice that has the
the
it will unload automatically the kernels
needed for this planet or this satellite
or whatever so we have
very precise data
right
it'll download the correct epicycles
right exactly
which is basically how it works
um
okay
all right well great anything else we
should cover right now
no i don't think so
i think we we probably need to continue
a bit with the
with the date stuff there are other
things to look at
okay fine and and we need to loop back
on the graphics of the um
uh
you know vector maps and so on yep
those things will be really great we
just need to
finish
polishing
okay see you all soon thanks to folks on
the live stream for your comments